maybe but will he live to regret having
the black pieces that's the big question
the games are
beginning five extra minutes for Magnus
Carlson could be decisive he needs to
win however Magnus with white plays the
Spanish it's the Spanish on the board
and we're going to quickly jump into
Toronto with Levy and James and their
thoughts on the bids we saw and the
opening that we are seeing right
now thanks Tanya yeah the opening
definitely a bit of a surprise I mean we
have some sort of weird uh we have an
open Spanish which I think is definitely
in Fabiano's wheelhouse I just want to
say something we were going to stand
here as commentators and say wow Magnus
bid 10 that was his max he knew Fabby
was going to bid 958 and then he said I
had no idea what's right it was funny
yeah you know I was going to be like oh
that's so so such a brilliant read by
and then he just goes yeah I had no clue
they have so little time to make that
decision that's true bro it's very quick
I mean and of course 958 usually you see
Magnus is the one that does it like
Magnus is the one that always out bids
You by one or two seconds here so Fabby
may have a little mental edge here here
you see how Magnus was pissed basically
you can just tell this is not the
friendly Magnus right now he's trying to
close out and I do just want to say this
open Spanish as we're about to throw it
back there to Oslo for them to get into
the X's nose this is an open Spanish
this is not a closed Spanish white black
has taken the pawn on e4 lots of theory
here so Fabiano despite the time
disadvantage is going to get to play a
ton of moves that he already knows 100%
And then after that it's just maybe
three or four critical decisions correct
he might be in good shape I think it's a
great choice as well open Spanish you
get a lot of moves in as Notre back said
before when you you know you need to get
to like move 60s you get that extra time
and stuff like that so this is going to
be exciting especially we have an open
Spanish so yeah man we might have we
might have two tiebreaker matches today
all right Oslo take it away thanks guys
uh James you're right no increment until
move 60 for the players where they get
after which they get a 1 second
increment now Fabby gets the result odds
the draw odds starts with 9 Minutes 58
seconds on the clock and to me that's a
pretty good bargain yeah I think he's
done everything right in the opening uh
Levy and James there kind of referred to
it the open Spanish it's one of the most
forcing lines as well in chess in
general like Fabiano he gets black gets
draw odds gets an opening he knows in
and out tension will be minimal here it
feels like everything's gone right for
him still early stages but uh I'm loving
what Fabiano's done with the bid and
with the opening FAO does have one
unhappy memory though on the black side
of an open Spanish and that occurred in
Madrid last year against hiar Nakamura
it was an open Spanish a forcing line of
material imbalance five and lost that
game and with it his chances at a world
championship title but we see in this
game he is solid in the center that
Knight on e4 looks like it's under
attack but that just leads to a series
of exchanges that black is not unhappy
about and after Knight to D2 I've been
wondering can at some point black push
the F Pawn that looks a little bit risky
maybe instead he should put his Bishop
out on F5 and it resembles what nybeck
and Wesley had in their match this
tension on the E4 square and to release
that tension you can trade pieces and
you can start with trading the knights
and then put the bishop on F5 as you
suggested trying to get rid of as many
minor pieces as possible a draw would
mean that Fabby wins the match Magnus
with white has to create his chances he
has to but how he pauses now when the
most obvious recapture would be by
developing White's Bishop uh the white
Dart Square Bishop on C1 hasn't moved
why not take back this Black Knight but
Magnus he's looking for something
creative because at some point he'll
need to surprise Fabiano he'll need to
switch it up maybe hit him with a and
kind of shocking unex expected move and
maybe he takes with the queen to try and
bring the White Queen closer to the king
side but either way I still love Black's
position and Black's chances in this
game the clock differential has now
reduced to only four minutes and
material might reduce if he takes with
the bishop on D2 just developing his
undeveloped Bishop then black pushes the
pawn the center up to D4 and suddenly
it's not just things are blowing open
that the white King's in any danger but
pieces are leaving the board and Fabiano
still has so much time on his clock 8
minutes 34 seconds a reminder everybody
that once they reach move 60 then
there's one second added for each and
every move you make so this move Queen
takes D2 I think it's trying to meet D4
with that Queen escaping over to the
king side perhaps trying to initiate an
attack well I've played these positions
with black as well and you're absolutely
right there are two ideas either black
tries to trade off the light squ Bishop
with the move Bishop F5 we see Fabby go
for that I think the problem with the
immediate D4 is also you have to
calculate what happens if the white Rook
slides onto to the open D line and
that's why Magnus chose to vacate that
square and capture with the Queen Bishop
F5
to me it looks like Advantage Fabby out
of the opening he's already managed to
uh to swap off two pairs of minor pieces
and that's good news when you're
fighting when you're looking for the
draw yeah I simply don't see anything
wrong with Black's position and Tanya
you made this uh I mean this exclamation
Because a queen trade in a must-win
situation it's counterintuitive right
that's what I would think Robert Queen
F4 and I would grab that Queen if a draw
is what I needed for the match Victory
but going into an end game again Magnus
gson is always a scary thing and it's
not just Magnus the type of position
that we have here because while Black's
position does look healthy a few things
stand out to me that pawn on C7 I see a
diagonal opening up and that pawn on C7
can be attacked if the pawn goes up to
E6 and he just goes forward with D4 and
look at Magnus that C7 Pawn really is a
weakness and look at the advantage bar
it's going up for white it's even the
evaluation bar is showing an advantage
for white what does Fabiano have
prepared once this SE file opens think
he's planning to move his Knight
unfortunately you don't have time to
come out with your bishop and skew the
white Rooks because uh ultimately the
white Rook on E1 is defended by White's
Knight so this would be a poor choice
white would be up two pieces for one
black rook and uh two pieces better than
the rook in this case instead I think
he's banking on Knight to B4 coming for
this Pawn but also trying to head back
into the middle of the board what he
might have underestimated or only now
realized Fabiano is that after Rook
takes Pawn the Knight dropping back yes
this is a fork yes is a double attack
but if the white Rook just moves
suddenly black is stuck this bishop is
attacked so Knight takes Bishop Rook
takes would just be a trade and white
would emerge a pawn to the good and if
you move your Bishop out the way to try
and gain time against whites Rook wh
Rook can save the day swoop up and
defend its Bishop either way Magnus is
winning a pawn and he goes for it and
maybe this is the moment that you stop
and the idea you pointed out threat is
better than the execution stronger than
the execution do you just simply defend
that Bishop on E7 with the move that
you're pointing out and now I'm
attacking your A2 pawn and Knight D5 a
big move on the board coming up it's a
tough call though because there's a lack
of clarity here so many pieces remain so
Fabiano spend some time right now and
realizes that if I start with this
Knight D5 in the live position and TR
off he instead he does go for Rook E8 I
think it is a good call but I say you
have to assess do I actually go down one
pawn and that's okay because all Rook
end games are drawn it still would have
been a tough sledding ahead but he
decides to go Rook e eight and now with
A2 pawns threaten Knight D3 Knight D5
all sorts of Knight jumps that white has
to worry about I'm liking back's
position right now there are all these
threats on the board I'm planning to
equalize the material uh for Fabby he
hasn't burnt that much time on the clock
although I do see that Magnus is still
ahead by 5 minutes what do you think how
would you evaluate this position David
it's tough I don't think we can make
generalizations here I think it's very
concrete if white isn't able to fend off
one of these threats or if white isn't
able to save this Pawn then black is
safe black is fine and will easily make
the draw so Magnus should spend as much
time as possible here uh as much time is
as is practical and decide what to do
next the biggest threat of all is Knight
to D5 we should mention hitting the Rook
hitting the bishop so you need to move
one of these two pieces essentially uh I
think there's simply no other option
Knight to D5 is a winning threat so he
moves the bishop out the way maybe he
could have gone in a different direction
but he's aiming to trade off and go for
the F7 Pawn Magnus I'm really surprised
he didn't invest much more time there
because uh there were options available
but still testing Fabian done it I think
he's going to continue testing him
because if we just go down one move
Knight D3 looks like it solves all of
Black's problems hits The Rook hits the
B2 pawn and the E5 Pawn all at once is
there E6 can you throw in that move just
causing chaos because if you take the
Rook on E1 that's not a free rook
because e takes F7 is check I get the
Rook right back and you see the
evaluation is all the way at the top
because white is not just one p and will
likely win a second at the very least so
this is something that maybe Magnus is
going for it's not just a trick I think
it is just objectively a good decision
and then the black king isn't feeling so
safe yeah and if you take this Pawn
suddenly There's real Targets later in
the game and okay Fabiano Dodges this he
plays F6 and big question for Magnus do
you drop back and maybe lose your
winning chances or do you go in and uh
hope to muddy the waters Magnus sitting
back in his chair looks shocked he's
reaching out and he does go in he's
going for the aggressive approach The
Rook on d8 is hanging is it time to
start stepping up with that Rook to
Target White's Queens side pawns how is
Fabby going to react to this and let's
also to point out if Fabby loses this
match he is out of the finals he needs
to get this game to get to a third set
like Wesley so was able to accomplish
and this is such a critical moment
because our first Temptation probably
for everybody to save The Rook but all
the way up to D2 putting pressure on the
pawns but I'm realizing that once white
pushes the pawn forward to E6 we have a
protected pass pwn from The Rook behind
it and that black Rook can actually take
the pawn on B2 it's stuck to that D6
Square because if the Knight you push a
pawn they get your Night Out suddenly
black is not able to deal with all the
threats and after E6 I don't really know
what black does I mean this as we're
showing is just going to be losing I
don't know how Fabby holds on here I
think he just simply forgot that Magnus
could keep the ewn alive he wanted to
trade it off at all costs but he didn't
have enough time Fabiano and suddenly I
mean this Pawn is just a monster there's
always tactics actually even on the back
Rank and I don't even see a good move
for black you cannot move this Knight I
mean if you go in for example Knight D6
I think your idea Robert still on the
cards if you remove this Rook remove the
blockada White's Pawn will just motor
through and
promote Fabiana in big trouble suddenly
and four minutes on the clock this
turned in the space of one or two moves
he was on the brink of safety but
suddenly letting it slip Magnus with the
e- pawn big favorite and everything
started so well right you start with
this open Spanish you quickly Blitz out
the moves you're able to trade off the
pieces really quickly the pressure is
dissolved and then these last two moves
just inaccuracies by Fabby big trouble
can't take the pawn on B2 can't put the
knight in the way of The Rook the most
important move to stop for Fabiano
Carana right now do not allow Magnus to
go Knight to D6 that E Pawn will become
a queen yeah but how do you stop that
eventually happening if you keep your
black Rook on the defile it means you're
unable to go and grab pawns Black's
Knight can never really recentralize
because uh then you block the defile
allowing it to happen again okay I have
a question what if Fabby just doesn't do
anything makes a move like A5 I'm
waiting how do you improve his white
hair St pushing pawns to the king side
Queen side yeah there are going to be
some options there at some point if I
get my king off the first even Rook D7
comes into mind but what I'm looking at
right now is black I think is one tempo
short of Knight C2 back to D4 going
right after that E6 Pawn because David
made an excellent point they're actually
a back ranked Checkmate ideas just to
show Knight C2 Rook to E4 and then
Knight to D4 and you go Knight D6 here
it looks like you just blunder this Pawn
E6 with let's say even Knight takes E6
or Rook takes E6 just grabbing that pawn
but I can just take you on E6 and then I
back rank Checkmate you so of course
there are going to be moments where you
can get away with something like this
but not here not when your king doesn't
have any Escape squares beautiful
beautiful tactics and this type of thing
if not is this exact variation this type
of thing will keep recurring it's all
about the black king being stuck right
now and uh at some point I guess this
Knight just might be booted out he gives
his King some breathing space so so
guarding against those motifs we
mentioned the black king now can at
least mobilize but how does Magnus
continue that is the big question is
there a way forward can he eventually
brute force it and push this Pawn to
Glory still some work to be done for the
world number one I'm much better waiting
move a kind of a waiting move by Fabby
the move H5 like you said just giving a
lift to Black sking and now ideas of
Knight C2 or Knight D3 are in the air
Magnus putting pressure on the clock
reaching out to make his next move Fabby
does hit the under three minute Mark
still far away far far away from meeting
move 60 getting that additional second
so it's not only keeping it on the board
but Fabby also has to avoid getting
flagged 2 minutes and 55 seconds in this
position you have to reach move 60 just
to get that bonus time with every move
made and this is such a tricky moment
for Fabiano Carana but Magnus is doing
the right thing investing some time here
because perhaps you could put the game
away not caring about the clock even if
you gave 5 a day you see the evaluation
bars all the way up here I'm already
looking at ways to go after the H5 Pawn
if I can land a rook on h8 my coach
always taught me about dream moves that
would be checkmates a rook back to C5 at
some moment that looks very enterprising
to me trying to go for the black king
yeah I love it Robert or pick up the
white Rook on E1 somehow plunk it on h8
Rook E4 Rook H4 take the pawn uh yeah
all these ideas popping through Magnus
Carson's mind right now he must sense
that he's doing well and I think the
moment it became tactical he banks on
his chances uh both on the board and on
the clock but still he wants the
accuracy these top players are
perfectionists they don't want to let
any opportuni slip and okay he's pausing
what to do first does he push a pawn
kick away the Black Knight does he lift
the white Rook up the board does he I
don't know push White's kingside pawns
forward there's so many options for
Magnus Carson critical moment he's in
the tank now 2 minutes once he starts
playing I'm expecting a quick flurry of
moves it's where players often go wrong
though when they're too many choices you
think this one looks just as good as the
other but there could be a flaw and you
could give black just the necessary time
to get back in the game and black does
have some threats a knight coming into
D3 that hits the Rook on E1 hits
multiple pawns and for Magnus he paus
and he does bring his Rook up to E4 so
any knight jump here doesn't come with
an attack against that rook and Rook H4
Rook takes H5 Rook h8 Checkmate not out
of the question yeah far from out with
the question and first of all posing a
difficult question to Black's Knight
three possible squares I think you
simply have to move that Knight perhaps
you can defend it with Black's Pawn but
uh there's downsides there's pros and
cons to every single night jump and
Fabiano it's basically a one and three
one and4 I even forgot that this was
possible but it's so far offside now
that black knight it's not coming back
into action anytime soon Magnus
therefore has the luxury of a few turns
to really uh close in either push the
pawn or go for that black king as we've
mentioned that Fabby levels the material
for now but in that that deal he does
put his Knight completely offside does
this give Magnus enough time to try and
go for the check mating idea that you
pointed out sliding The Rook to the
hline the one defensive resource that
Fabby has is to push that g Pawn to G6
to make sure that the H file remains
blocked and at least for the time being
Rook h8 will not be Checkmate probably
definitely does not want to open up the
seventh rank but it may be a sad
necessity just to avoid that immediate
demise so G6 at any moment for black
does defend that pawn that's sticking
out there but that seventh rank being
open is very dangerous so I'm looking at
this for Magnus everything does look
good but if if you go Rook H4 Pon I
actually don't see how to end the game
and that's good news for Fabiano he may
believe he's got a Fighting Chance under
two and a half minutes right now he
doesn't only have to fight the board
again he has to fight the clock as well
it is what is that it's 35 moves to make
it to move 60 and that's a far way off
with complications still on the board
the ewn two steps away from from
queening so there are checkmating ideas
on the king side you have to avoid
White's Knight jumping onto D6 the pawn
promoting further to E7 there's a lot to
fight for in this position how is Fab
going to manage this it's not going to
be easy I think Fabiano's moves will be
influenced by magnus's moves right now
the Black Knight simply fixed on A2 no
retreat squares Black's Rook stuck
defending the D6 square and uh actually
I'm looking for mag Magnus just
manifesting just imagining perfect pawns
perfect pieces if white could land a
Pawn on F5 protect his Advanced e- Pawn
he's simply winning so maybe push the
pawn to F4 he actually defends that pawn
with his rook and the eval bar slides
slightly down uh this idea I think is a
dual purpose threat firstly attacking
Black's A6 pawn and secondly creating
that D6 Square for the White Knight to
hop back to and it frees up the E4 Rook
as well to go on over to H4 but Fabby he
backtracks with his own rook and the A6
Pawn can be captured so white will be a
pawn ahead but that black knight it
survives it goes up to C1 and then may
back around to D3
if Fabby could pick up that Knight and
place it on E5 to trade off a pair of
knights he will have better chances but
his Knight's been offside it's not a
good piece and Magnus he maintains this
uh momentum and I just feel like for
Fabby every single move is so
challenging and to make it a good piece
Fabby thinks it's worth giving up upon
is Magnus going to allow Fab's Knight
back into play he is reaching out I
think for the Rook to capture that A6
Pawn but hesitates pulls back does not
look happy though he does not look uh so
convinced that it's totally winning we
see the eval bar but I think it's
deceptive as white you know the stakes
are high if a set of Rooks disappear if
the knights ever disappear drawing
chances only increase so you need to
still continue being energetic and
accurate to maintain this Advantage he
tries to trade off the Rooks now because
that would allow the White Knight to
come back to more active squares the
White Knight ultimately is the one that
will remove the Blocker of the E Pawn I
think this was a key move for Magnus
Carson yeah and that white knight will
not only jump to D6 but if black Rooks
Rook moves forward to E7 it will attack
it further from that F5 Square
eventually getting that E6 Pawn rolling
down the board Fabby cannot afford to
let that happen side steps with the rook
and The Rook is back on the seventh rank
Knight D6 once again a threat on the
board that's the killer blow for Fabiano
the death now because he wants to bring
his Knight back into B3 he does just
that but once you get Knight D6 in here
the the only thing that Magnus need to
be care about is if that black knight
gets a C5 that Forks both of his Rooks
so Rook C1 check followed by Knight C5
at some moment unfortunately after
Knight D6 his Rook on E8 is under attack
so I don't think he's going to survive
this one o watch out there a threat of a
draw right now Perpetual check Black
Knight if it comes down to F1 checks the
white king and uh wh King cannot escape
and Magnus with a headshake he was not
expecting to move Knight to D2 he
thought he had it in the bag when he
played Knight D6 and Fabby throws a
curveball with this one big threat he's
lucky he's still winning Magnus Carson
after missing this nasty sneaky move the
white Rook is attacked but you cannot
move it if you move the white Rook or if
you capture the black Rook draw on the
spot the Black Knight comes to F1 check
forces the white king back and we'll see
a yo-yo the black knight move discover
check and uh this dance will last
forever Magnus needs to give some space
to his King it's the type of move that
completely rattles a player you can see
Magnus he needs to regroup right now and
just like yesterday when he's the one
who sacrificed his Queen Fabiano finding
a des try but he pushes a pawn does
Magnus Carlson he trades off a pair of
Rooks G7 is now loose so Magnus despite
the initial shock he still found the
best continuation that's where having
time on the clock is such a lifesaver
here Fabiano simply doesn't have enough
time down to just over one minute we're
only at move 33 increment a distant
dream it's going to be a race on the
clock even if he weren't losing this
position but it does unfortunately look
like that white ewn is going to decide
matters whites King now given enough air
to survive on its own he will take take
care of itself the other white pieces
will get job uh get the job done and
okay he's sliding behind good try from
Fabiano trying to put his Rook behind a
pass Pawn that's what we're taught in
all positions but it's just collapsing
the G Pawn is now up for grabs but don't
take it with the Rook because if you
take that pawn with the Rook the king
steps the side hitting the Knight on E8
the Knight can't move because the it's
the only piece defending that Rook over
there so Magnus still has his work cut
out for him five and0 creating a
challenge but now that pawn is one
square way from promotion and I think
it's going to get to the other side and
Magnus gson taking his time this could
very well be Fabiano K's very L moments
in the Champions Chester final and you
can see it in him uh and Magnus knows
he's close to victory in this one Fabby
pushes the F Pawn is there a night jump
Knight moving to C7 do you do you have
the path right now to get that E Pawn to
E8 perhaps although the Black Knight
goes back to F6 and holds things for now
that's why Fabiano has vacated the F6
Square with this Pawn thrust but it is
desperation Magnus doesn't need to break
uh kind of this formation actually black
is stuck black can barely move anything
at all the White Knight jumping out the
way you can play that at will later on U
maybe he'll play it now maybe he'll move
the Knight he can even take the G7 Pawn
if you want to be really flashy with the
white knight but uh I'm expecting Magnus
to just take a calm approach not allow
any counter play or any tricks at all
well I mean is down to 42 seconds and
this may be the last 42 seconds of his
entire event here if he l he's
eliminated look at that move G5 taking
away that Knight's backtrack beautiful
move from Magnus Carlson there just
removing any defensive hope at all yeah
look at Fabiano in pain oh he's got no
time simply under 30 seconds now and I
think he's just coming to terms with
everything that's happening because it
is not just about losing this game
Fabiano Carana will be eliminated he
will be knocked out of the Champions
chest off finals he takes a break he
does pick up the pawn but now that
Knight will not jump back to F6 to guard
that E Pawn from promoting there's a
check on F3 but I think it's only a
check and Magnus needs to pause
calculate he does it he realizes that
Knight F3 is just a check grabs that G7
pawn and it's handshakes favano Carana
is eliminated Magnus Carlson stamps his
ticket to the finals and what a great
game there from Magnus he even missed a
tactic he was shaken but he was able to
regain his composure he eliminates
Fabiano Carana but congratulations are
in order to Magnus Carlson